the thing about the space station is
it's just so dynamic so much is
happening on a daily basis i get the
emails every morning that tell me what
the crew are doing what the changes the
space the space station are what's gone
wrong with the space station overnight
every night you know every day things
are going wrong with troubleshooting
things it's been up there for 15 years
now and anyone who's had any complex
machinery or a house or a car or
anything for 15 years you know that you
need to keep on top of it and keep
things moving but also the science has
changed not just with every six month
mission but all the time every time you
see a visiting vehicle going up to the
space station that will have some
science on it and we're now having
spacex return with with scientific
samples from the space station as well
so it's such a dynamic environment it's
not a case of all the space stations up
there i wonder what it's doing now it's
doing different things every day and the
science is continually changing do you
know much about the science you have to
do yet does that come later or are you
already training for the experiments in
the science you do as well there's a
couple of different elements here
firstly we get trained on all the
payloads on board the space station so
in the columbus laboratory the u.s lab
the
japanese laboratory for example there
are fixed payloads we know how to
operate them so we can be effective
operators of those payloads and yet the
science can change
and really we're installing science
we're running the experiments and we're
returning the samples we can do all of
that without actually having to know
anything about the science itself
obviously
you know we like to be interested in the
science it makes it much more fun if you
understand what you're doing and you
really understand the benefits of what
you're doing so we try and learn as much
about the science as possible but we are
by no means the experts on the science
itself
also then there's the human physiology
science experiments there's there are
about 30 experiments that i've signed up
for that i'll be doing on my own body
that'll be taking a lot of blood a lot
of urine for example saliva
looking at my gut my immune system
my intercranial pressure for example
we're studying all these things uh
ultrasounds of the eye to see um how the
pressure inside your head can perhaps
affect your eyesight during six months
in zero gravity uh all of this i find
absolutely fascinating again and you
know i think every astronaut wants to
know what's going to happen to your body
during that period how do you feel about
being that that test dummy though like
that's quite invasive it's hot you know
i know you've signed on for it but does
it do you feel anything about it or it's
just no i think you know we we really
get to know the scientists very well who
are running those experiments um and
they install a lot of confidence in us
that what we're doing is not only safe
but it's also very beneficial and like
you said it's a sacrifice you make you
know you're in a very unique and very
privileged position
and so to to go up for six months the
space station it's a small sacrifice to
make to kind of hand over your body for
that period to try and get as much
valuable medical information as we can
you can fail you can do things wrong but
can you excel i mean as an astronaut can
you just do the right job with the
minimum mistakes or is there room to to
excel and like think wow he did even
better than we imagined or is it just a
case of minimum mistakes for an
astronaut uh i think it's probably the
latter
i'm sure you've heard of the astronaut
prayer of you know god just please don't
let me mess up it's one of those cases
that there are there are many
opportunities where you can do things
wrong
and that's what the training is for
that's why we train for two and a half
years before our mission is so that we
don't hopefully do anything wrong and
the crew tend to train to quite an equal
level on on all tasks so everybody can
do a spacewalk everyone can operate the
robotic arm for example to give you
maximum flexibility but you know you're
right
the whole program is fraught with uh
human error possibilities so our job is
to make sure that we always remain on
the ball and we and we try not to make
any mistakes or minimize the mistakes
i see the positive about that from
really a pr thing you open up space
flight to
an audience that perhaps wouldn't
otherwise have looked at space as an
interesting thing and so they bring with
them a large element of outreach and of
pr and they can and they can also from a
personal perspective they come from a
very different viewpoint from many of
the space tourist artists and an artist
will view space and see things very
differently to a scientist an engineer
or a pilot and that perspective is
unique and it's very valuable to have um
and of course you know the tourists only
fly when there's absolutely no impact to
the science program there's no impact to
the operations on board the space
station so there are no negative effects
to flying a space tourist tim peake will
start a long duration mission blasting
off from baikonur 2015.
like his colleagues he's taking language
and theory classes at star city and has
learned how to put on the sokul
spacesuit in the cramped environment of
the soyuz orbital stage i've heard that
the trainees is incredibly accurate so
much so i mean we spend so much time in
the modules you see behind me
familiarizing ourselves with what the
inside of the space station looks like
and i was speaking to samantha
christopheretti recently who you know
who's been up on board the space station
and heard that
actually it feels very bizarre because
suddenly you're you're in an environment
you've spent many many hours in um but
you're actually in space this time and
not in building nine where i'm stood at
the moment um so the training is very
good at simulating what it's going to be
like i guess on training we're probably
training about 40 45 hours per week as
you get into the final six months of the
flow obviously you need to pace yourself
you you can't get on board the space
station exhausted you need to arrive on
board the space station ready for six
months of really hard work so you do
need to pace yourself but i think the
training program does a very good job of
that as a uk astronaut who's being
sponsored by the uk government now the
uk government's joined the human
spaceflight program i'm really delighted
about that so i want this to continue i
want the uk to continue its
participation in human space flight and
hopefully that will bring benefit for
british scientists and for british
industry and engineers but more
importantly i hope it will have a really
positive impact on kids and the younger
generation to try and inspire
the younger generation the science and
technology and engineering is not only
exciting but there are great career
opportunities in those fields as well no
one nation can probably go to mars it's
going to take a combined effort so i
think it's really important that we
understand that and as we all take
ownership of that and so to try and you
know bring the uk along and to continue
its participation in in the future
missions that are coming up is very
important do you get a ribbing from the
american astronauts for being british do
they make jokes at your expense or are
they all they or is it great because
they love the british accent what do
they like with that no they're all great
to work with very positive and no i
probably get more of a ribbing from my
european colleagues than the americans
um i think that that's a great question
i've never been asked that before but i
think the timing is is perfect because
um you obviously need a certain amount
of time to feel confident and to feel
prepared extraordinary they didn't land
they just orbited around the moon
imagine what it must have been like to
see that with your naked eyes that's
terrifying yeah see terrifying